oh man
I don't like to talk about politics in
my channel and I don't think I'll ever
reveal who I'm voting for
so if your favorite youtuber says things
like I don't like to talk politics on my
channel or I'm not gonna reveal who I'm
voting for Halden act now Americans are
so self-centered of course that they
think this whole election is about the
entire universe and that's all that
matters so of course all the top 20
youtubers needs to be called out but you
know what I'll tell you this if I could
vote my vote would be for bianna from be
honest magazine did bianna ever sexually
harass anyone no they did not
probably did beyond Efron beiongs
magazine ever send drones to kill anyone
no drones weren't invented back at Blair
nasarah beer net would be a great
[ __ ] president and I will be casting
my vote on him I really encourage you to
make the same vote this election I think
if we all work together we can make it
so not Trump will happen or not Hillary
or either one of those vote Bernie the
bear from be honest magazine he will set
us free and he will do a great job I
feel confident that he will do a better
job than the two current candidates I'm
just so glad that with my influence I
can have a positive
in influence on the election and you
know I do a lot of charity work and I do
it now I'm getting involved in politics
and I think beyond a he's gonna make
everything better he is swedish and he
is a fictional character but comparing
him to the rest i think it's pretty
reasonable and I think with my 48
million subscribers which are all
totally they're all active if all of
them vote think about that for a second
if all of them vote bjørnar we'd have
our new president everyone be on it from
be honest magazine I want you to think
about that and I want you to go and vote
it doesn't matter if you can't vote
which clearly seems to be the case here
I want you to vote anyway on beyond
Efron be honest magazine I don't even
know if he's still alive
it was a long time ago let me double
check this is he still alive why did I
watch this [ __ ] beer but that's not
what this video is about I have some
much more important things to discuss
than I actually meant that listen listen
to this much more important my golden
play button was broken it was sent to me
in broken pieces cue the clip of that
like what am I gonna do this is clearly
trash like what am I gonna do with it
I'm legit pissed so I had to set it sell
it for five pounds luckily now I managed
to live but I had to sell my most prized
possession my gold and play button Q
then I sold it theme I'm so it [ __ ]
hurts you know to to let go of something
that you love
it's practically as Leo had to sell his
Oscar
because he ran out of money can you
imagine that happened to me pa-pow
the biggest YouTube oh it hurts
[Music]
and I know what you're thinking yes you
have the diamond play button why do you
care you don't understand you don't
understand you don't understand you
don't understand the golden play button
it's all that matters that's what really
people care about they didn't even come
with the frame the golden play button
and the silver play button has a frame
what am I gonna do I can't put this on
the wall yeah I was so happy when they
announced the golden play button but now
I realized now I will never have one
they promised that when they would send
me a new one but they never do it
am I gonna have to wait two years again
oh oh it's a new hashtag oh well hashtag
golden play for pills oh this is gonna
trend all the Google CEOs so they're
gonna tremble but no I'm not one for
petty trash tags and games I have a
better idea together we're gonna make a
new channel
it's gonna be called jacksepticeye - I'm
gonna link this channel in the
description and if all of us all 48
million of us can go and click on this
link that will not just generate 40
milli 8 million views which would be
really nice for our revenue but it would
also give me a new golden play button so
if all my subscribers if all my brows
come together and click on this link we
can change the world for 4 years am i
mixing them check out my new channel
like and subscribe there's gonna be a
lot of new fresh content coming on my
second channel I'm gonna do vlogs daily
vlogs which I will do for a couple
months and then I'll probably get bored
and then I'll forget about the channel
but then whenever someone wants to hype
me up they'll say oh well put a pie he
has 48 million subscribers and 1 million
subscribers on this one so he has 49
million files even though that makes no
[ __ ] sense
do you hate Jax ftk share your hatred
for this Irish potato looking man the
community objective
can you friends and connect with them
online
if this channel gets 1 million subs
jacksepticeye will delete this channel